this is the most prestigious car we have
to offer it's very exclusive it's very
powerful my name is Wolfgang dilemma and
I'm the president and CEO of bentley
motors of course the best place in the
car for me as an engineer is still the
driver seat here you can enjoy the sheer
power the acceleration from 0 to 100 is
only 4.9 seconds and to build this
beautiful car text 400 hours this is the
ultimate working atmosphere we have in
the Bentley Mulsanne so when I'm
traveling from a to me I enjoy to look
through my presentation I think it's the
fastest and most luxurious office on
wheels this is really a very luxurious
one is our bottle cooler that is
installed right in between the two rear
seats and by the press of a button it
opens up and there comes the cool
champagne and some very nice handcrafted
classes the price for this very
exclusive package is three hundred and
ninety thousand euros we will probably
sell around a thousand units per year
our customers you like to have upgrades
it's hard to believe that 500 horsepower
is not enough this
eat more is better